olonne au palais royal il est l'un des
rares artistes français à connaître une
carrière internationale
alors si vous aimez les rayures la
provocation et l'art contemporain je
vous invite dans il ne faut jurer de
rien a adopté la buren attitude
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre l'examen de la proposition de loi
sur le repos dominical
hier la discussion générale a été
particulièrement animé les sénateurs de
la majorité comme ceux de l'opposition
s'étaient en effet mobilisés pour
examiner ce texte polémique malgré des
voix discordantes au sein de l'ump la
majorité devrait voter ce texte conforme
avec le soutien des voix centristes
je vous rappelle que cette proposition
de loi autorise le travail du dimanche
dans les communes touristiques ainsi que
dans les grandes zones commerciales de
paris lille et marseille
ce matin la discussion reprend à
l'article 2 tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle bonne séance à tous l'ordre
du jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de loi réaffirmant le
principe du repos dominical et visant à
adapter les dérogations à ce principe
dans les communes et zones touristiques
et thermales ainsi que dans certaines
grandes agglomérations pour les salariés
volontaires dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'article 2 sur l'article 2 j'ai
plusieurs demandes de parole on peut
commencer par notre collègue me suivent
roger madec
vous avez la parole ainsi monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mais
chaque collègue la proposition de loi
que nous étudions ce matin et le
quatrième texte de projet de
déréglementation du code du travail on
ne te ra l'acharnement du gouvernement à
vouloir légiférer sur cette question le
choix du passage en session
extraordinaire pendant l'été n'est pas
anecdotique pas puisque la volonté dans
votre conformes ou la procédure
accélérée le gouvernement ainsi que le
président de la république se veulent de
la rupture
plutôt que de rupture je parlerai de
retour en arrière sur les grandes lois
fondatrices de maths république voulons
défendre un projet sociétal plus juste
et moigne égalitaire france de constater
que cette proposition de loi conduira à
la version adoptée le repos hebdomadaire
prend sa source dans la loi de 1906 qui
établit une journée de repos de madère
pour tous les salariés dans un objectif
de protection de la santé
cette loi de 1906 nous en trouvons la
substance de l'article 1 qui a été votée
cette nuit
mais derrière cette façade se cache un
texte qui était une véritable chimère
pour le salarié il s'agit d'un choix de
société que nous voulons défendre celui
de la liberté du salarié les nombreuses
dérogations que prévoir votre texte ne
rentre pas dans ce cadre il ne rentre
pas dans le choix de ce projet de
société que nous voulons
al'inverse vous nous proposez une
société basée sur la justice l'égalité
et la consommation
une france à plusieurs niveaux face à
une autre une france où l'on travaille
le dimanche et une france on voit on
consommera sans vergogne le dimanche
une france où les liens familiaux sont
cassés par la loi du marché je vous le
dis ne voulons pas d'une société où l'on
peut consommer 365 jours sur 365
car loi de niveler les inégalités ce
texte va les accroître
posons nous cette question quels sont
les salariés qui seront concernés
réellement par ce texte
la réponse est simple ceux qui occupent
des emplois rénumérés par les bas
salaires
il est temps partiel essentiellement
occupés par des femmes
enfin en bref tous les emplois atypiques
et à ce sujet parmi les modes vous
arrêtez sais m'arrêter
en ce moment nous sommes confrontés à
une vue flambée de la violence notamment
dans l'est ce qu'on qualifie les sites
et pourquoi pas si bien souvent les
jeunes sont livrés à eux mêmes y croyez
vous que les femmes seules les enfants
issus des familles monoparentales seront
mieux encadrées quand les maires devront
aller travailler le dimanche je ne crois
pas aux cris de travailler plus pour
gagner plus vous nous parler du pouvoir
d'achat ah je vous prends au mot accepté
les amendements qui oblige l'employeur à
doubler le salaire horaire le dimanche
naturellement épargnez moi l'argument
madame la rapportrice monsieur le
ministre que l'on va pas payer double
les infirmières le dimanche parce que
les médecins et les pompiers
l'opinion publique est parfois les
salariés eux-mêmes croit en général que
le travail dominical un pic le versement
d'une majoration salariale et d'un repos
compensateur
cela est vrai mais seulement dans le cas
des cinq dérogations du maire et
lorsqu'un accord collectif le prévoit je
vous le rappelle pour mémoire la
majoration salariale et le repos
compensateur ne sont pas de droits lors
de son discours d'euros tel le 28
octobre dernier le président de la
république interpellait les maires sur
les familles qui ont le droit
les jours elle ne travaillez pas d'aller
faire leurs courses dans les magasins
qui seront qui sont ouverts et pas
systématiquement fermé le dimanche
moi je serais tenté de dire à mes
collègues sénateurs maires ou élus
locaux
pensez donc à ses enfants comme le
rappelait tout à leur issue des familles
monoparentales qui ont le droit aussi de
participer à des activités autres que
d'attentes leur tour de leur mère ou
leur père seul le dimanche
léon salto rapporteur de l'avis du
conseil économique et social
consommation commerce et mutations de la
société indiqué en 2007 que le dimanche
doit rester un point fixe structure en
permettant de se retrouver et de
consolider la cellule familiale
de plus en plus éclatées et dispersé
c'est aussi un temps privilégié pour les
activités culturelles sportifs ludiques
touristique associatif
la rencontre avec les amis la
disponibilité sociale au service
d'autrui
donc le support de la cohésion de la
société le texte préconisera levante
arias monsieur le ministre nous savons
qu'il n'ya pas de volontariat dans le
code du travail
du fait de ce lien de subordination
entre l'employeur et l'employé de la
précarité de l'emploi de la faiblesse
des salaires très peu de salariés
pourront refuser de travailler le
dimanche sans risquer de perdre l'emploi
soixante et onze pour cent des salariés
du privé pense qu'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de refuser le travail et si
leur employeur le leur demande de le
faire le dimanche
alors pensez vous bien que dans les
zones concernées pas des dérogations
administratives
l'accord entre l'employeur et les
délégués du personnel seront dans un
seul sens c'est de cette france que nous
voulons pas cette france partagée entre
ceux qui parviendront plus et ceux qui
travaillent en plus les conséquences
sont désastreuses
les zones touristiques
les zones à visites touristiques et les
périmètres d'usagé de consommation
exceptionnel la création de ces trois
zones finiront par couvrir presque la
totalité du territoire et seront de
facto applicables à la presse qu'à
l'ensemble des salariés vous considérez
que seules 500 communes sont concernées
nous nous en allons bon de 5000 à 6000
le calcul est aussi simple que la loi
est floue actuellement notre pays contre
24,7 millions d'actifs et près de 7 4
millions travail le dimanche ou peuvent
travailler le dimanche
une fois la loi votée à combien se
chiffreront ses salariés obligés de
travailler le dimanche
alors vous entendu cette nuit et hier
après midi avant ces deux cent mille
personnes
c'est vraiment le cas pourquoi faire une
loi par ailleurs une étude commandée par
un dos prédécesseur monsieur renaud
dutreil me du commerce en 2006 pas
suspect pour ses idées de pencher à
gauche
concluait à la perte de près de 200
mille emplois dans les commerces de
proximité en cas de généralisation de
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
face à cette hémorragie comment survivre
on les commerces de proximité
face à la concurrence des grandes
surfaces les forces de constater que
hélas le petit commerce disparaît dans
beaucoup de zones et ce petit commerce
était un élément structurant pour les
grandes villes mais aussi pour les zones
rurales
si vous cherchez des fêtes regardez du
côté d'ebay canada blement suédois
ouvert le dimanche qui peut s'aligner
face à des hôtels entreprises il y aura
un déplacement des chiffres d'affaires
réalisés aujourd'hui par les petits
commerces par les grands groupes
je serais tenté de dire que votre
proposition de loi que la proposition de
loi que vous soutenez est une aubaine
pour ces grands groupes de la grande
distribution
il est illusoire de penser que le
consommateur va consommer plus en effet
le push ardeur le pouvoir d'achat n'est
pas extensible
les achats dominicaux se substitueront à
ce vide que la semaine et monsieur le
ministre
épargnez moi l'argument déjà dit déjà
entendu je crois que vous êtes
enseignant de formation vous avez été
longtemps ministre du cassiot nationale
vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer que la
meilleure pédagogie c'est que de répéter
je serais tenté d'essayer de vous
convaincre
si vous acceptiez un bon nombre de nos
amendements peut-être que nous pourrions
réviser une position sur le vote final
du texte
et surtout si votre bonne foi n'est pas
en compte j'ose espérer que vous
accepterez comme un amendement mon
collègue café sur le statut dérogatoire
pour y apporter à la capitale de la
france honnêtement je ne comprends pas
cette provocation dans ce texte
bref je vais pas anticiper sur le débat
je vous remercie la parole était à notre
collègue madame marie-thérèse hermange
je rappelle que ces cinq minutes 1 nous
n'arrivons donc à l'article 2 de ce
texte c'est à dire le coeur du texte qui
prévoit d'apporter des réponses à deux
types de situations clarifier le régime
juridique applicable à certaines
communes touristiques et offrir un
nouveau régime dérogatoire pour
certaines grandes agglos rage
agglomération je sais que richard maillé
et isabelle debré honteux vrai dans un
souci de protection des travailleurs
mais en dépit du caractère rassurant de
l'article 31 32 3 du code du travail
selon lequel dans l'intérêt des salariés
terme qui a été ajouté leur pop de la
mer est donné le dimanche je peux
m'empêcher de m'interroger sur le champ
des dérogations représentants de la
collectivité parisienne
comment d'abord admettre que paris ville
touristique par excellence ne soit pas
sous le régime du droit commun et que le
préfet de paris décide à la plage du
maire sans même que celui ci dit son
conseil ne soit consulté
j'entends monsieur le ministre que vous
avez dit hier qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
préfet qui décide mais récemment nous
avons voté une loi sur l'hôpital où il
nous a été demandé il y à un mois de m
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
sous le régime du droit commun pourquoi
dans certains cas paris doit relever du
droit commun et dans d'autres doit-il
faire et ses excès plus exception
représentants des collectivités locales
je m'interroge aussi sur le déséquilibre
territorial
que risquent d'introduire certes
arctique et ce à un double titre d'abord
à terme il risque de créer des
inégalités territoriales
d'autant que l'ancrage des entreprises
dans l'ain territoire passe aussi par
l'implantation d'entreprises à forte
valeur ajoutée qui ne seront pas
forcément des grands
face et qui devrait se faire dans des
conditions adéquates à celle ci par
exemple lorsque ces entreprises
aujourd'hui ont des dérogations et
qu'elles ne sont pas inscrits dans des
zones touristiques et thermales 4
viendront elles devront elles fermées le
travail du dimanche tel qu'il est conçu
dans ce texte me semble rompre le
principe d'égalité des entreprises entre
elles et en conséquence risque de
déséquilibrer dans le temps l'ancrage
territorial de certaines entreprises
ils risquent peut-être d'accroire aussi
la désertification de certaines communes
et contribuant à créer des villes
dortoirs supprimant alors cette place de
rencontres qui est l agora que rousseau
dans son discours sur l'origine des
langues nomme la fontaine qui permit aux
communautés de se rassembler et de faire
miroir en sortant les hommes de leur
isolement et que d'autres nomme la
paroisse pour autant alors compter sur
nos concitoyens pour nous aider à
développer notre territoire
d'autant que dans ces villes
l'éclatement du lien familial et social
sera manifeste comme il est aujourd'hui
et que l'on n'aura pas créer une cité de
l'hospitalité je m'interroge aussi sur
les conséquences en matière de mode de
garde pour les collectivités l'octet
rite orial car désormais en a à n'en pas
douter les dispositifs de mode de garde
seront nécessaires pour accueillir les
enfants dont les parents soit par choix
soit parce qu'ils ne pourront pas faire
autrement devront faire prendre en
charge leurs enfants par une structure
adéquate une assistante maternelle
faudra-t-il alors que les collectivités
locales ou par an on assure la charge en
la matière et si les structures
n'existent pas pour apple ont déploré
que des enfants soient livrés à eux
mêmes
et puisqu'il est question d'enfants ne
devons nous pas nous demander si nous
faisons acte de civilisation et de
respect à leur égard
ce risque à plus long terme c'est le
rôle du politique de le soulever de le
nommer et cela n'a rien à voir avec une
peur panique face aux changements
enfin monsieur le ministre en faisant
des dérogations le principe
c'est à dire autoriser le travail du
dimanche et du principe des dérogations
le travail de médical n'a plus à se
justifier
c'est au contraire le repos dominical
qui doit prouver sa justification
justification d'être ce temps de
rencontre avec l'autre l'autre certains
l'écrivent avec un grand a et les
chrétiens savent que le christ et
appelle à ce rendez vous qui est le
sommet de leur semaine d'autres
l'écrivent avec un petit tas et le
perçoivent comme un lieu de détente de
gratuité de joie toute simple pour
retrouver les siens ou de vivre des
rassemblements familiaux sportifs ou
associatif
d'ailleurs souvenons nous qu'au xixème
siècle lors des débats houleux sur le
dimanche
ce n'est pas le chrétien ozanam qui
défendu le repos dominical mais aussi le
socialiste at et proudhon
à vrai dire le principe du repos des fds
au madère protège la vie des familles et
a pour vocation de se retrouver soi-même
et de rompre la solitude c'est un temps
qui n'est plus celui de l'euro de
l'horizontalité mais de la profondeur
tente il n'est pas guidée par des
impératifs exclusivement économique
si dans les faits de cet article de loi
n'apporte pour l'instant par de grands
changements nicolas bour dit à juste
titre ni panacée ni poison
il comporte vous en conviendrez monsieur
le ministre
une modification qui porte sur le
symbolique et aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous dire je voudrais le dire aussi à
mon président de groupe que vous me
voyez perplexe car je n'ai pas
l'habitude de déroger à la discipline de
groupe
je les fais à deux occasions dans cette
assemblée lors de l'article du texte sur
la fin de vie et lors de la
transposition d'une directive sur le
médicament dont je ne suis pas sûr que
les uns et les autres nous avons pris la
mesure de ce que nous avons voté cette
époque qui permettait
de faire de l'embryon et médicaments oui
je suis perplexe aujourd'hui et je
voulais le dire ouvertement aux bruins
devant notre assemblée et devant notre
prise en deux groupes les en même temps
monsieur le ministre vous devrez vous
remercier voudrais aussi remercier
monsieur mallet d'avoir inscrit cette
proposition doit paradoxalement car
personnellement elle m'a fait
redécouvrir le sens du dimanche et je
crois qu'à la vérité
le noeud finalement de la contreverse ne
réside pas dans tel ou tel interdit ou
prescription de se voir si demain ou non
on va faire un homme caddie ou non mais
fait quelque part dans la vocation
originelle du dimanche qui me
semble-t-il de mettre l'autre en rollat
de mettre l'homme en relation avec
autrui
je vous remercie de votre attention
madame annie david vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
2 aura entre autres pour effet
d'autoriser dans les zones et communes
touristiques et thermales le travail
obligatoire des salariés le dimanche
sans contrepartie ni financière ni de
repos compensateur en effet le travail
le dimanche deviendra de droit mais
plutôt devrais-je parler de zones de
travail de non droit pour les salariés
puisque il s'agira de zones dans
lesquelles leurs intérêts ne seront pas
respectés
pour ces femmes et ces hommes au travail
le dimanche qui permettront aux
touristes internationaux de venir
dépenser leurs devises
il n'y aura rien ni rémunération
supplémentaire ni repos compensateur
comme si sous prétexte de satisfaire les
aspirations commercial de quelques-uns
notamment les plus fortunés il fallait
sacrifier les équilibres familiaux ou la
santé des autres pourtant chacun
s'accorde à dire que les emplois de
commerce provoque fatigue et stress et
que ces mots vont grandissant les
salariés connaissent d'importants
troubles musculo-squelettiques
douloureux pour les hommes et les femmes
qui les subissent mais dans les
conséquences économiques sont
importantes
cela intéressera sans doute notre
nouveau rapporteur général à la nacelle
mais d'après l'assurance maladie les tms
sont la première cause de reconnaissance
de maladie professionnelle
ils ont engendré en 2007 la perte de 7,4
millions de journées de travail et 736
millions d'euros de frais couverts par
les cotisations patronales ses effets
néfastes tant sur les comptes sociaux
que sur la santé des salariés auraient
pu être mesurée par une étude d'impact
que vous avez refusé et tout fait pour
éviter monsieur le ministre avec votre
gouvernement en optant pour la voie
d'une proposition de loi plutôt qu'un
projet de loi aussi au regard du travail
obligatoire dans les zones touristiques
le second alinéa de cet article 2 qui
prévoit je cite dont l'intérêt
des salariés le repos hebdomadaire est
donné le dimanche prend un goût amer
faut-il encore que l'intérêt des
salariés ne viennent pas contredire les
intérêts économiques et ceux de la loi
du marché lors de la discussion de votre
rapport madame debré vous nous avez
présenté le repos le principe du repos
dominical comme un principe anciens
madame procas ya quand elle a parlé de
disposition d'un garde voire archaïque
nous considérons au contraire qu'il est
d'une grande modernité face à un
principe encore plus ancien celui de la
domination de l'économie sur l'humain ce
qui est datée bien au contraire c'est le
retour que vous nous proposez à la loi
de 1802 permettant aux employeurs de
choisir le jour de repos de leurs
salariés en raison des besoins de
productivité
mais au-delà de ces considérations
d'usagé de santé publique votre refus de
remy nérée celles et ceux qui
travailleront le dimanche dans les zones
touristiques et thermales est une preuve
de votre volonté de banaliser le travail
dominical
vous voudriez faire de cette journée de
travail exceptionnel une journée de
travail comme les autres du moins dans
les zones touristiques pour commencer et
justifier ainsi l'absence de
compensation par des besoins structurels
je le dis avec force les salariés de
notre pays qui par leur travail
permettront aux entreprises ou aux
établissements d'accumuler de la
richesse doivent pour le moins en
bénéficier il est vrai que pour vous
cette rémunération peut être prévu dans
les conventions collectives
à vous écouter il faudrait demain sous
prétexte d'une plus grande liberté pour
les salariés supprimé le code du travail
et l'ensemble des protections
collectives au bénéfice de la seule
négociation de gré à gré votre fameux
gagnant gagnant dire cela c'est
méconnaître profondément le monde du
travail et les contraintes qui pèsent
sur les salariés liés par un lien de
subordination à leur employeur ou bien
c'est vouloir les tromper car ce sont
les employeurs qui sortent vainqueurs de
ces négociations gagnant gagnant et vous
le savez bien
enfin je voudrais vous mettre en garde
ou tout au moins vous alerter sur les
conséquences judiciaires de ce texte qui
seront de deux ordres
tout d'abord vous affirmez madame la
rapporteure que ce texte renvoie pour la
définit
dans des zones touristiques à celle
donnée par le code du travail
or la rédaction proposée en recourant à
la notion de zones d'intérêt touristique
tels qu'utilisés dans le code du
tourisme et j'ai vérifié c'est bien une
une notion qui est dans le code du
tourisme sera source d'ambiguïté pour
les préfets et de contentieux devant les
tribunaux administratifs
aussi afin d'éviter que les contraintes
qui pèseront sur les salariés déjà trop
nombreux des quelques 500 communes
reconnues touristiques au sens du code
du travail ne s'étende aux salariés des
5000 communes reconnues touristiques au
sens du code du tourisme
nous avons déposé un amendement qui
permettra à votre majorité d'affirmer sa
volonté de ne pas étendre le travail du
dimanche et au préfet de s'appuyer sur
cette rédaction pour les futurs
désignation enfin la distorsion des
droits des salariés que vous créez dans
ce texte aboutira aussi à contentieux
comment accepter que dans une ancienne
nationale implantée dans différentes
zones touristiques puce ou bien ailleurs
sur notre territoire non couverts par
une zone spécifique les contreparties
acordées aux salariés soient différentes
cela a fait l'objet de notre motion
d'irrecevabilité et malgré vos arguments
qui ne m'ont pas convaincu je persiste à
dire qu'il y aura discrimination entre
les salariés à l'issue de ce texte
la parole est à madame isabelle pasquet
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avec cet
article de nous en arrivant au coeur de
cette proposition de loin celui qui
organise la généralisation du travail le
dimanche
cet article est elle d'un central qui
constituait à son origine l'article
unique de la proposition de loi du
député mallet ainsi sous couvert de
faire cesser une situation complexe
reposant sur de nombreuses dérogations
180 le député mme allier at il proposé
de revenir à une règle datant de 1906
instaurée pour protéger les salariés et
les ouvriers
une protection qui recueille aujourd'hui
encore le soutien d'une majorité de nos
concitoyens puisqu'ils sont 55% à
refuser le travail du dimanche
les envieux et place d'une loi de
simplification nous débattons
aujourd'hui d'une loi qui apportera
encore plus de troubles fait renaître
d'importants contentieux alors même que
l'un des ses principaux objectifs était
de régulariser la situation des centres
commerciaux de certaines villes le plan
de campagne en tête
régulièrement condamnées par les
tribunaux administratifs en ce sens et
c'est clair cette ppl s'apparente à une
primo délinquants une loi d'aministie
déjà les entreprises condamnées ne
montrez pas leur empressement à payer
leurs amendes il faut dire que la
justice ne montrez pas non plus beaucoup
de rigueur pour exiger ce qu'il dit
comment voulez vous nous faire croire
que les entreprises hors la loi hier
voire même condamné ne vont pas
s'estimer dans leurs droits avec effet
rétroactif et donc encore moins encline
à payer leurs dettes
comment va faire l'état pour exiger de
ces entreprises de répondre de leurs
responsabilités antérieures
intérieurement à cette loi votre
gouvernement monsieur le ministre qui ne
cesse de durcir les sanctions notamment
l'égard des récidivistes n'hésite pas
ici
soutenir une proposition de loi comporte
concocté fait sur mesure pour une
minorité de magasins appartenant très
souvent à des grand ancien pour ce faire
vous créez les puces les périmètres
d'usagé de consommation exceptionnel
dans lesquelles le travail le dimanche
sera généralisé et d'égaliser ce qui
permet aux centres commerciaux de val
d'oise et de plan-de-campagne de
réintégrer la légalité
cette réintégration justifie selon d'où
une loi d'exception
ce que nous ne pouvons accepter vous
avez même affirmé durant l'examen de
certains articles 2 à l'assemblée que
pour vous les français doivent
travailler plus bel aveu de votre
défiance à l'égard de nos concitoyens
qui justement touchés par le chômage et
les temps partiels imposés ne demandent
qu'à travailler
c'est d'ailleurs très souvent le cas des
hommes et des femmes est majoritairement
des femmes qui travaillent le dimanche
précisément parce que leurs revenus
hebdomadaires ne leur suffisent pas à
vivre dignement
alors justement vous vous appuyez sur
cette situation de précarité pour
justifier votre ppl un peu comme si les
salariés de notre pays devait accepter
toutes les déréglementations la perte de
tous leurs repères l'anéantissement de
tous leurs droits pour avoir la
possibilité de gagner quelques euros de
plus et encore nous n'aurons pas le
droit dans les puces eux-mêmes à une
majoration de salaire seuls les nouveaux
salariés ceux embauchés dans un puce
après l'adoption de cette proposition de
loi auront droit au repos compensateur
et percevront pour ce genre de travail
une rémunération au moins égale au
double de la rémunération normalement dû
pour une durée équivalente à moins que à
moins qu'un accord collectif ne vienne
prévoir des contreparties inférieures à
celles prévues légalement
indéniablement cette inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes dessert les
salariés et permet aux employeurs de
s'aménager les lois à leur mesure
quant aux salariés contraints de
travailler le dimanche dans les zones et
ville touristique
ils et elles n'auront tout simplement
droit à aucune contrepartie et motif
qu'ils et elles n'auront pas été
volontaires pour travailler le dit
et bien c'est précisément parce que ce
travail s'apparente comme une contrainte
supplémentaire subi par les salariés
qu'il faut organiser une réelle
compensation ainsi au final entre les
salariés des puce embauchés avant et
après l'adoption de cette loi les
salariés des zones touristiques
les dérogations accordées cinq dimanches
par an par le maire secteur le travail
dominical est permanent et les 180
dérogations qui est qu'ils résisteront
cette loi la législation 1 sera d'autant
plus complexe
une seule certitude si les actionnaires
profiteront pleinement de cette
législation est salarié e seront une
fois encore les victimes d'une société à
6 sur le tout commerce
car si la parole est à madame barry
zaguiri monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la loi
qui nous est soumise aujourd'hui porte
mal son nom
réaffirmant en théorie le repos
dominical dans son article 1er l'article
2 de cette ppl légalise de fait des
infractions actuelles étend le champ
d'application des exceptions contient
les ambiguïtés problématique
c'est par ailleurs un curieux procédé
que d'afir